julien combes et qui ne vous parle pas
des points d'agen mais 18 parades et de
son grand concours qui passionne toute
l'aquitaine c'est très simple dit titre
vous en sélectionner trois une carte
postale fun boîtes postales 70 33000
0,30 bordeaux cedex nous tirerons au
sort et plein de cadeaux à gagner le
vainqueur du jour s'appelle hervé cholet
il habite au haillan et nous envoyer une
superbe carte postale représentant la
mairie et l'église et il gagne 10 maxi
45 tours une cassette un 33 tours et une
place pour aller voir franck & gas
hollywood il y aura d'autres places de
concerts à gagner dans la prochaine
émission
je vous propose tout de suite de
retrouver les dix titres de la semaine
qui vous permettront de gagner tous ces
cadeaux je prends mes pompes et je vois
qu'il ya marc lavoine en premier bascule
avec moi alain bashung malédiction look
the loop la griffe de l'animal goûts de
luxe
les yeux de nora serge domini rend moins
de 10 watts et pierrot bruno ghislain
chanel sanaga ragga je laime quand même
philippe cataldo les divas du dancing
plein sud
nulle part ailleurs et philippe guillot
les yeux cernés je vous donne
rendez-vous dans quinze jours pour nous
envoyer vos cartes postales et n'oubliez
pas qu'elles sont conservées afin de
participer au grand tirage qui vous
permettra de gagner un voyage
destination soleil sur air france a donc
un jour ça lui